es sind wohl zehntausende funkmasten
millionen an wlan routern und außerdem
unzählige handys die alleine in
deutschland elektromagnetische felder
erzeugen die angst ist und bleibt groß
dass diese strahlung gefährlich für uns
ist was ist da dran und helfen viel
umworbene und teure gadgets um uns davor
zu schützen klicks ums ganze wirtschaft
die gibt's drei mal pro woche spannendes
heinz videos abonniert den kanal denn
nur so verpasst ihr nichts los klaus
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen pixum gibt es
übrigens auch als podcast der link ist
hier unter me und unten in der video
beschreibung in diesem video geht es um
elektrosmog der uns in unserem alltag
auf schritt und tritt begleitet und das
obwohl wir entweder sehen riechen noch
hören was genau elektrosmog ist kann die
wissenschaft dabei gar nicht eindeutig
beantworten
den begriff smog kennt man
beispielsweise aus china wo die
großstädte wie von nebel eingehüllt
scheinen die luftverschmutzung dort
allerdings ist auf emissionen
zurückzuführen es handelt sich vor allem
um erhöhte stickstoffdioxid werte und
eine erhöhte konzentration an feinstaub
partikel in der luft der begriff smog
wird von den beiden englischen wörtern
smoke also rauch und fog nebel gebildet
meint also so etwas wie eine besonders
schwere schadstoffbelastung der luft bei
elektro smog sind allerdings
elektromagnetische felder gemeint und
zwar sowohl niederfrequente als auch
hochfrequente und das macht einen großen
unterschied zumindest physikalisch
gesehen handelt es sich hierbei um zwei
verschiedene phänomene die auch
verschiedenartige wirkung auf den
menschlichen körper haben können
niederfrequente elektrische und
magnetische felder werden von
elektrischen geräten wie beispielsweise
elektroherde oder waschmaschinen
verursacht hierbei liegt die strom
frequenz bei unter 100 hertz bei uns in
deutschland sind zb 50 hertz was die
anzahl der schwingungen pro sekunde
meint wenn solche geräte mit dem
stromnetz verbunden sind sind diese
immer von einem elektrischen feld
umgeben selbst dann wenn das gerät an
sich ausgeschaltet ist auch die
versorgungsleitung sind permanent von
elektrischen feldern umgeben sobald wir
dann die geräte nutzen und tatsächlich
strom benötigt wird entstehen zusätzlich
noch magnetische felder deren intensität
sich nach dem jeweiligen
verbrauch richtet die magnetischen
felder sind in der lage auch wände und
mauern zu durchdringen doch es sind
nicht nur elektrogeräte in unseren
haushalten sondern elektrische felder
existieren auch an versorgungsleitungen
und verteilerkästen doch durch häuser
sind wir davor ganz gut geschützt mauern
und wände verringern die feldstärke bis
zu 90 prozent
hinzu kommen außerdem noch überirdische
hochspannungsleitungen eine der
hauptquellen niederfrequente felder
denn die kann man übrigens auch ganz
einfach sichtbar machen neonröhren
fangen unter hochspannungsleitungen an
zu leuchten ohne dass sie angeschlossen
sind heftig diskutiert werden aber vor
allem die hochfrequenten felder die
wichtigsten quellen sind unter anderem
handys wlan-stationen funksender anlagen
radio und fernsehsender sowie mobilfunk
sendemasten hier treten elektrische und
magnetische felder immer parallel auf
und der schwingungs bereich liegt
zwischen 100 kilohertz und 3 100
kilohertz ohne diese hochfrequenten
elektromagnetischen felder könnten
unsere smartphones weder daten noch
sprache übertragen doch diese
elektromagnetische strahlung ist nicht
ohne
den sieg am fenster dachziegel und auch
dünne mauern durchdringen das bundesamt
für strahlenschutz bfs schreibt dazu auf
seiner webseite hochfrequente
elektromagnetische felder werden vom
körper aufgenommen absorbiert und können
dort unterschiedliche wirkungen
hervorrufen die stärke der energie
absorption hängt von der stärke und der
frequenz der elektromagnetischen felder
ab aber auch von den eigenschaften und
strukturen des biologischen gewebes dies
liegt daran dass wir menschen genau wie
andere lebewesen auch aus vielen
elektrisch geladenen teilchen und
polaren molekülen bestehen
durch die kraft elektrischer und
magnetischer felder werden diese in
bewegung versetzt und so entsteht wärme
und genau das kann nach ansicht der
fachleute vom bundesamt für
strahlenschutz dazu führen dass
hochfrequente felder auswirkungen auf
den menschlichen körper haben
in einem gewissen umfang ist der körper
in der lage diese wärme auszugleichen
dazu schreiben die wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler auf der bfs website
wird der körper nur ordentlich begrenzt
erwärmt so kann in der regel das blut
die zusätzliche wärme abführen wird der
ganze körper erwärmt so wird die haut
stärker durch
und die wärme wird durch verdunstung an
der hautoberfläche abgegeben schwitzen
tierversuche aber haben deutlich gemacht
dass gesundheitliche folgen drohen wenn
bestimmte schwellenwerte überschritten
werden denn dann wird die
wärmeregulierung des körpers gestört in
den studien war dies der fall wenn sich
die körpertemperatur um deutlich mehr
als ein grad celsius erhöht hatte und
das über einen längeren zeitraum hinweg
in den tierversuchen konnten dann
verhaltensänderung beobachtet werden
stoffwechselvorgänge wurden gestört und
auch bei der embryonalentwicklung gab es
störungen
bei den experimenten wurde deutlich dass
vor allem der bereich des gehirns und
die roten besonders wärme empfindlich
sind
auch der bereich der augen zeigte sich
als besonders empfindlich hier führte
eine langanhaltende überwärmung dazu
dass die entstehung von grauem star und
anderen augenkrankheiten begünstigt
wurde manche fachleute vermuten dass
durch diese erwärmung noch mehr im
menschlichen körper passieren kann
können moleküle brechen und kann dadurch
krebs entstehen
dazu gibt es aber noch keine eindeutigen
hinweis unumstritten aber ist dass unser
herz kreislauf system durch eine
dauerhaft erhöhte körpertemperatur
leidet vor allem das handy haben viele
von uns sehr nah am körper um
informationen zu übertragen entstehen
hochfrequente elektromagnetische felder
und das beim telefonieren meist direkt
am kopf zumindest wenn man ohne
freisprecheinrichtung telefoniert die
fachwelt kann nicht mit eindeutiger
sicherheit sagen was das für unsere
gesundheit bedeutet was macht eine
intensive handynutzung über mehr als
zehn jahre mit einem erwachsenen und wie
wirkt sich die nutzung von handys bei
kindern aus zumindest gibt es
international festgelegten höchstwerte
die vor den risiken schützen sollen die
rede ist vom sogenannten saar wert eines
tablets oder smartphones und das steht
für spezifische absorptionsrate dieser
wert gibt die maximale sendeleistung des
geräts an die den menschlichen körper
bleiben telefonieren mit diesem gerät
also potenziell gefährlich werden könnte
alle handys die in deutschland und dem
restlichen europa verkauft werden müssen
den grenzwert von 2 watt pro kilogramm
körpergewicht einhalten
doch klar ist auch dieser wert wird
unter laborbedingungen gemessen ist
daher keinen wirklich zuverlässiger
indikator dafür wie strahlung uns beim
täglichen gebrauch des handys
täglich umgibt denn diese
maximalleistung ist im alltag nicht
nötig solange sich das handy in der nähe
einer mobilfunkzelle befindet allerdings
schon im auto oder im zug die ja als
faradayscher käfig strahlung abschirmt
sieht das anders aus sie dämpfen die
strahlung von außen und werfen die
handystrahlung zurück spricht die handys
punkten dort mitunter mit
maximalleistung und diese wird dann auch
noch auf uns zurückgeworfen heißt also
im klartext bei guten
empfangsbedingungen sendet das gerät mit
einer erheblich geringeren sendeleistung
als bei schlechten empfangsbedingungen
dennoch die wissenschaftlichen
unsicherheiten bei diesem thema bleiben
und so rät das bundesamt für
strahlenschutz dazu sich möglichst wenig
elektromagnetischen feldern auszusetzen
und die exposition vor allem im privaten
raum so klein wie möglich zu halten
bei der sogenannten interphone studie
von der weltgesundheitsorganisation und
des internationalen
krebsforschungszentrums irc in lyon
haben mehr als 12.000 menschen
teilgenommen hier ging es um den
regelmäßigen umgang mit dem handy und
inwieweit das krebsrisiko
dadurch erhöht wird im visier vor allem
krebs des hörnerv der ohrspeicheldrüse
und hirntumore der untersuchung zufolge
konnte bei einer durchschnittlichen
nutzung des handys für einen erwachsenen
menschen kein erhöhtes tumorrisiko
festgestellt werden doch die
studienleiterin elisabeth cardis
schränkt dieses ergebnis gleich ein
aber wir können daraus nicht folgern
dass kein risiko besteht denn es gibt
genug hinweise die auf eine mögliche
gefährdung hinweisen die kritik an der
studie ist groß und das aus mehreren
gründen zum einen sind einige fachleute
mit der auswahl der probandinnen und
probanden nicht einverstanden denn
teilgenommen hatten nur handy
nutzerinnen und handy nutzer zwischen 30
und 59 jahren dabei gibt es studien die
vor allem bei den 20 bis 30 jährigen auf
ein erhöhtes krebsrisiko hinweisen zum
anderen hatte die mobilfunkindustrie die
studie mit 5,5 millionen euro
kofinanziert auch das wird kritisch
gesehen
der bund für umwelt und naturschutz bn
de spricht von praxisfernen bedingungen
der studie und wie zitat keine
entwarnung geben es sind vor allem zwei
weitere studien die in diesem
zusammenhang immer wieder genannt werden
beide untersuchungen wurden 2018
veröffentlicht aber bereits vor 15
jahren 2005 gestartet
unter anderem im auftrag der
us-gesundheitsbehörde fdp beide
experimente hatten untersucht wie sich
ein netz von mobilfunkstrahlen auf
ratten und mäuse auswirkt in dem
amerikanischen experiment handelt es
sich um die strahlungsdosis die auch ein
handy in den usa während des
telefonierens abgibt in der anderen
studie aus italien war es eine deutlich
geringere dauer bestrahlung die tiere
waren dem feld schon im mutterleib
ausgesetzt die ergebnisse der beiden
untersuchungen stimmten quasi über ein
und das obwohl sie unabhängig
voneinander durchgeführt worden waren
die tiere hat nach einer zeit die 55
menschlichen lebens jahren entspricht
hirntumore entwickelt und zwar nicht
irgendwelche sondern äußerst
ungewöhnliche und tumore zudem bekamen
die nagetiere geschwülste an den herz
nerven sehr seltene schwan omen dazu die
pathologin fiorella belp hockey die an
der italienischen studie beteiligt war
als ich diese daten sah wusste ich
sofort wir haben hier ein echtes problem
eine bestimmte häufung in einer studie
kann immer zufall sein aber wenn sich
seltene tumore in zwei unabhängig
laufenden studien häufen dann ist das
nicht mehr mit zufall zu erklären denn
beide tumorerkrankungen hängen
biologisch gesehen zusammen sie
betreffen das bindegewebe dass die
nervenzellen voneinander isoliert diese
alarmierenden ergebnisse der
italienischen analyse gibt das bundesamt
für strahlenschutz auf eine zu hohe
exposition der ratten demnach würden
sich menschen in einem normalen handy
netz niemals so stark erwärmen
da sie ja deutlich größer seien die
tumore die sich bei den tieren
entwickelt hatten könnten demnach also
auch eine direkte folge der
temperaturerhöhung seien zudem sei die
italienische untersuchung auch noch
nicht abgeschlossen denn bislang wurden
nur die herzen und gehirne der tiere
analysiert schlüssig ist diese
argumentation nicht denn schließlich
gibt es auch keine studien darüber dass
es in wärmeren klimazonen zu hören
krebsraten kommt warum also sollte es
wahrscheinlicher sein dass die tumore
durch die krebs auslösende wirkung von
wärme entstanden sind als durch die
strahlen wirkung selbst
doch auf der anderen seite ist auch klar
dass sich solche tier laborversuche
nicht eins zu eins auf menschen
übertragen lassen menschen sind bedingt
durch ihren wasseranteil leitend und die
verwendeten elektromagnetischen strahlen
lassen sich
reicht von leitenden materialien
ablenken außerdem sind die körpergrößen
von menschen und ratten natürlich enorm
verschieden und auch deswegen lassen
sich diese experimente nicht ganz so
einfach von tier auf mensch übertragen
die mobilfunk quellen dringen nur einige
zentimeter in das gewebe ein und so
können sie zumindest bei erwachsenen das
herz überhaupt nicht erreichen aber
aufgepasst denn die menschliche
großhirnrinde beispielsweise liegt nur
einige wenige zentimeter tief und könnte
somit also von den mobilfunk quellen
erreicht werden vor allen dingen durch
ein handy am ohr und tatsächlich das
deutsche krebsregister sieht eine
leichte zunahme bei den hirntumoren
bislang schiebt man das jedoch auf eine
verbesserte diagnostik die
us-amerikanische gesundheitsbehörde fdp
dagegen hat insgesamt 125 tierversuche
und 75 menschen versuche analysiert
demnach gebe es zitat kein einheitliches
muster um hochfrequente strahlung mit
tumoren oder krebs in verbindung zu
bringen
dennoch gibt es auch von dieser seite
aus den dringenden appell diesen
möglicherweise heiklen thema in weiteren
studien nachzugehen
laut dem bfs bezeichnen sich übrigens
etwa zwei prozent der deutschen
bevölkerung als elektro sensibel diese
menschen geben also an ein
elektromagnetisches feld zu spüren vor
allem die hochfrequente strahlung vom
wlan und mobilfunk die betroffenen
leiden unter kopfschmerzen oder übelkeit
bisher ist allerdings wissenschaftlich
nicht nachgewiesen dass
elektromagnetische strahlung wirklich
die ursache dafür ist und so hat die
weltgesundheitsorganisation wer dieses
leiden bislang nicht als offizielle
erkrankung anerkannt fest steht die
angst vor den strahlen ist gut fürs
geschäft und so gibt es mittlerweile
nicht nur bett unterlagen sondern auch
andere produkte wie beispielsweise
babymützen die vor elektrosmog schützen
sollen erst vor kurzem hatten
sicherheitsexperten vor einem anti fünf
gestik gewarnt der mögliche gefahren der
5d strahlung einschränkt der usb stick
mit der bezeichnung 5 gb schielt sondern
nach angaben der britischen hersteller
firma mit hilfe von quanten oszillation
und dank eines holografischen nano lea
katalysator elektrische wellen zitat
harmonisieren ein tief fachleute nahmen
diese stick genauer unter die lupe und
stellten dabei erschreckendes west
demnach handelt
sich um einen normalen etwa sechs euro
teuren usb stick mit einem aufgeklebten
sticker in online shops findet man außer
dem handy hüllen halsketten mit
vulkanischer lava und sogar boxershorts
die vor elektromagnetischen feldern
schützen sollen so auch der sogenannte
harmonisiere eine box aus plastik die
bis zu zwölf meter weit zitat
hochwirksamen schutz vor elektrosmog und
erdstrahlen bieten soll und das fühlen
nur 170 euro ein elektronischer
schaltkreise im inneren des harmonisiere
soll nach angaben der herstellerfirma
wie ein filter funktionieren
auf der webseite selbst findet sich dann
im kleingedruckten dass die
wirkungsweise wissenschaftlich nicht
bestätigt ist bislang ist die wirkung
des geräts noch nicht wissenschaftlich
bzw schulmedizinisch bestätigt worden um
die exposition wirklich niedrig zu
halten kann aber jede und jeder von uns
auf bestimmte dinge achten die wirklich
etwas bringen beispielsweise den samwer
checken wenn man sich ein neues handy
kauft eine freisprechanlage oder ein
headset nutzen wenig im auto oder zug
telefonieren und vor allem im privaten
bereich elektromagnetische felder
vermeiden
auf der webseite des bmw gibt es
folgende tipps entscheiden sie sich für
geräte die strahlungsarm kabelgebunden
und gut abgeschirmt sind verwenden sie
möglichst wenig elektrogeräte im schlaf
und kinderzimmer nutzen sie netz frei
schalter verwenden sie abgeschirmte
kabel mobilfunkfrequenzen verursachen
krebs ist handy strahlung gefährlich für
menschen hier gibt es mehr zu den
strahlen versuchen also anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren und zwar geht
es ums tanzen future diesen kanal hier
bis dann bleib dran